we're about to build the Shaquille
O'Neal trailer
I'm Jenna's Faison you may not know me
but you definitely know my business
partner big boy from The Mighty group
Outcast that can't be big boy
together we flip worn down RVs into
luxury rides
[Music]
but what we have here I don't know about
this folks money wise it wouldn't be
worth it while I'm the main designer
that's a diamond in the rock big boy
brings the wow factor and expert eye to
everything we do really though
[Music]
is a rock star ride satisfaction
guaranteed I really want to have a
luxury Barber Shop
Manny's pedis facials
[Music]
started doing that
come on man give me what you got baby
this ain't your ordinary renovation show
this is big RV remix